afternoon everybody
it is afternoon right
pretty sure
Tuesday there's what day is it Tuesday
Wednesday
yep okay
awesome I am going to assume that
everyone can see my slides up here at
this point I was like I can't see them
even though I've sat in this room and I
know where the slides are
so let's get started because I know
there's a lot of other way more
interesting stuff happening today
to get started show of hands who here
likes JavaScript
who here hates JavaScript
JavaScript is something that most
developers have at the very least heard
of even if it's from another developer
swearing at their computer trying to get
it to work
So today we're going to talk about why
you don't need JavaScript and how you
can build things without using any
JavaScript
so to start off I would like to
introduce myself hi my name is Amy I
have traveled a very very long way all
the way from Australia
and I'm really excited because this is
my first time in Copenhagen I've been to
a few different countries in Europe but
I've not made it to Denmark yet and so
I'm really excited to be in Copenhagen
with you all this week and that is only
slightly influenced by the fact that on
Saturday a bunch of us are going to
Legoland and Lego house I mean the
conference is fun but
Lego
I also have a beautiful dog who gets
very disappointed when I go away to
conferences and so he generally makes it
into my talk
now
I want to start off okay where
we kind of we're going to diss on
JavaScript a little bit here today in
case you didn't work it out but I want
to start off by preferencing this saying
JavaScript is useful JavaScript is a
useful programming languages and it is a
useful tool
but it's often over used
the thing is HTML and CSS in a lot of
cases are much lighter tools to use
so we're going to go through today and
we're going to build a bunch of things
using HTML and CSS only
I'm talking no JavaScript
that means no build tools using
JavaScript no npm packages
just HTML and CSS
so starting off I want to look at a
couple of HTML tricks
I'm going to start looking at some using
targeting content
looking at accordions and form
validations these are some of our very
common things we use JavaScript for
first off I'm going to look at content
targeting
can anyone here tell me what the link
tag is in HTML not in react not in xjs
not in one of the other things the HTML
link tag which one's that
a yes
the link tag or anchor tag is used when
we link to
another page or website a file or
resource so that could be an image or a
PDF or something like that or we can
also use it to reference the ID of an
element on our page or another page and
send the user straight there
this is really useful because if you
want to send them to the contact form
instead of sending them to one page you
can send them all the way to where the
content form is
so this will then change the url and we
end up with that hash value that appears
in the URL
but using CSS
we can actually check whether or not an
element is targeted as part of the URL
we can check whether that has already
uh whether that already exists as part
of the hash value
and use CSS
to change it
so I'm going to switch to do a bit of a
demo now this is a a very beautiful
website that I have built for today and
we can see here we have just a couple of
things here I've got an index.html file
there's some styles
I've got some graphics and images and
fonts that I'm going to load in and so I
have my HTML file here
this is what I'm going to go through and
do a lot of work in
but I'm going to open up one of my HTML
files here to get started
now because I don't trust doing live
coding demos
I have some CSS here what we can do is
we can go through and reference the
section element
and I'm then going to go through and
hide all of the section elements this is
where the content exists on the page but
I'm going to check if this section
element is targeted so if this the ID of
this section element exists as a hash
value in our URL I would like to display
it
what that does
is this means
I can
create a single page application of
thoughts with no JavaScript whatsoever
my header stays my footer stays but the
content
that exists
it displays and hides depending on my
hash value which we can't quite see here
because the URL bar isn't showing very
well but if I have a look here
I have here index.html hash toggle which
is the page I'm on I can then go to fax
testimonials home so I'm able to go
through and navigate
two different pages
of my single page application using
only HTML
Now browser supports one of the things
that we should probably be thinking
about in this case and on the bright
side Target as a selector has been
around for quite a while so it's
supported in pretty much all of the
browsers well
all of the well-used important browsers
that we like to work with
so this one is actually pretty good to
be able to use in production
I do kind of want to
preface
this though uh full disclosure
this involves working with the hash
value in our URL and isn't a great
alternative most of the time and it's
not spectacular for accessibility uh so
it's probably a good point to full
disclosure
a lot of what I'm going to go through
today is something that you can do
not necessarily something that you
should do
uh so we're going to go through and have
a bit of fun
but please don't go back and just word
for word Implement all of the things I
show in your production applications
because there are several reasons why we
don't do this
next
I want to look at accordions
so accordions something we often see
in an FAQ section we've got a bunch of
questions and you can click on it and it
expands out the answer
how do you normally do an accordion or a
collapsible section
anyone have anything they would normally
reach for
maybe a JavaScript package I'm sure
there'd be a JavaScript package that
would do this right
did you know
there was a HTML element well two HTML
elements actually there is the details
element and the summary element these
are used in conjunction with one another
and allow us to define a bit that's
clickable which is our question
and a bit of content that will appear or
disappear depending on whether our
section is open
so if we go through and have a look
at our FAQ section in our beautiful
application
already exists yeah
no JavaScript I actually don't have to
do anything here I've just used the
right HTML element
and I can go through and expand
and collapse
each of my sections
still no JavaScript
the details and summary elements have
pretty good browser support as well so I
did just say please don't go and
implement this stuff in production this
one you can this one is ready to go this
one is ready for production
uh full disclosure if you are having to
support I think I.E is about the only
one if you are having to support a older
browser the support's pretty good they
just all appear open rather than being
expandable and collapsible so that one's
pretty good but this is actually one of
the things you can continue to use
yourself
next
form validations
how do we do form validations
server side
that answer is not fun maybe JavaScript
might do that with JavaScript
we know we need to validate our form
inputs because do we trust our users to
input the right data
I'm actually seeing some heads nodding
and I do not believe any of you
we don't trust our users to give us the
exact data that we want in the format
that we want thankfully there are a
bunch of HTML things that we can use to
validate this without having to go to
JavaScript or even before it gets to the
server side yes we might be validating
the form submission on server side but
we can validate it on the page fairly
easily
first
is required fields
now this is one that's existed for a
while
we can add a required attribute to our
form field and it won't let you submit
the form if it's not filled in it's
great very easy to do if a field is
required make sure you're doing this
the other form of validation that we
often end up doing is the format that
the data is coming in
so this is really important for some
Fields like dates
and phone numbers
did you know that there is a native HTML
input which has a date picker
and a Time picker
and it's accessible and it works on most
devices and browsers and it works the
way users expect it to on their device
and browser and it gives it back in a
standard format
if I submitted a form with the date
zero nine one one twenty twenty three
is it in September or is it in November
zero nine one one
is it the 9th of November or the 11th of
September
depends where you are yes it depends
when you are but then there's still a
whole bunch of things that are based
in countries that do dates weird and
even if you might not expect it that's
the way we do it there is however a HTML
element which will give the date back in
a standard format it has a knight State
picker and it's ready for people to use
we can also define
formats for things like telephone
numbers we can define a pattern for how
we expect it to be filled in
so this is really useful for things like
if we want to get a country code along
with a phone number
I'm going to would I be safe to assume
that most of the time you're putting in
a country code with a phone number
here would you if someone asks for your
phone number in a form would you put in
the country code or just your phone
number country code
or just phone number
this often means we have to go back
through and validate things afterwards
or staff might break with the way we're
doing things but we can Define the
pattern that we expect so we can Define
to say okay we do actually expect a
country code to be at the start and it
won't let people submit the form without
it so if I have a look
at our contact form here
and I can fill in my phone number
well I didn't fill in my name
Amy
when did I learn first learn JavaScript
today
and phone number
please match the requested format
so I've defined that I would like to
have a country code if I actually put in
a phone number which is not my phone
number by the way so don't go try
please match the requested format but if
I started off with
plus six one
it doesn't want the Plus
there we go
what format have I given it
oh dashes okay that's silly
what was that four
anyone remember the format
phone
ah three three four
three
four I also have one number too many
there it's happy now it's happy with my
phone number and it will let me submit
the form so we can go through and
perform a lot of this validation on the
browser side without having to delve
into JavaScript or doing anything on the
server this is really useful because
it's such an easy tool to implement I
just recommend some better error
messages to people or telling them the
format that you're expecting
now
four
uh
my notes have not told me what element
this is for I'm going to Hazard a guess
that this is in terms of the required
element I think the required attribute
uh that one's been out for quite a while
and the uh tell attribute note date
picker a tribute
uh this is where we can go through and
this one has good support as well
uh full disclosure on this stuff as
we've seen there are limited validation
capabilities
uh you can add some JavaScript and that
allows you to customize the error the
browser gives back so worth looking into
if you're doing this
now that we've looked at some HTML we're
going to look at a bit of CSS and see
what we can do
there are quite a few useful things that
we can do with CSS and JavaScript like
nesting who here is familiar with using
a CSS preprocessor or post-processor so
we can nest
yep
uh rain sliders
another common one testimonial carousels
uh switch toggles and image carousels
which we love image carousels we so love
working with building and using image
carousels we're going to go through and
do this
gonna start off with nesting so quite a
few people were familiar with what I
mean when I say CSS nesting
this is actually native CSS now
browsers support the ability to write
nested CSS so we don't need to use a pre
or a post processor anymore I recommend
having a look at the exact standard but
this allows us to go through and rather
than writing div p
and then div PA and div p a DOT my
element
we can go through and Nest it and reduce
the amount of code that we're having to
write
this browser support this is very very
new
so it is supported in all major browsers
from this year only so probably not
something you want to use in production
just yet unless you can guarantee your
entire audience uh people who have the
most up-to-date browsers but this is
exciting to see it coming out and we can
reduce a lot of it most of the time that
I end up using a preprocessor or a
post-processor for CSS is because I just
I just want to Nest things I want to not
have to write out a whole string like
four times just to get something so this
is exciting to see
next
I want to have a look at range sliders
so you might be familiar with range
sliders we often use them for feedback
forms you are from a range of not happy
to very happy and kind of meh not either
of them is somewhere in between
now there's a HTML element for this
there's a form input of range and we can
define a minimum and a maximum value
which gives us something to work with
but
that often makes things a little bit
difficult because we need to convey
where people are going like am I rating
this out of a hundred or out of five is
this and how do those numbers relate to
where it is that I am for example anyone
familiar with the NPS rating system
a couple of people uh so it's how a lot
of companies rate customer service if
you you have met a support request and
they come back and they're like how
would you like to read our service we
want to know what we can do better and
you go well you know
they helped me but I didn't like that I
had to contact them so you give them
somewhere in the middle you give them a
5 out of 10. that's what you do if
they're really unhelpful you give them
less
the way the system works is anything
less than a seven
is negative
so everyone that goes well I'm not
overly happy but I'm not unhappy and go
as middle of the road is actually
marking them down these kinds of things
make it hard because we assume the
middle is neutral but we can add labels
to our range sliders which allow us to
more accurately Define what the
different options are
we can do this by adding a data list
element
we can put a whole bunch of options
inside that and we can then link those
through as up labels that appear next to
a range slider so if I have a look
here we have
a range slider
how much do you know JavaScript
I don't know
5 out of ten nine out of ten what's that
how how can I rate that
so we can go through
and we can actually Define
some slightly nicer values so that
people understand what it is that we're
looking for
I'm going to write a little bit more CSS
now so first of all I'm going to go
through I'm going to find my form
and I'm going to take advantage of
nesting I'm then going to use the has
selector now this is a bit of a new one
and
allows us to check what's inside of an
element what CSS selectors are inside of
an element without having to actually go
down into it so this is the close anyone
who's heard of people wanting a parent
selector this is about as close as we've
been able to get to a parent selector
and most of the time it does work
so I'm going to check for a form
but I'm specifically checking not radio
range I'm specifically checking for a
form that has an input of the type range
inside of it
I then want to check
so I can go through
and do it that way
I then want to get my input of type
range
and first of all I actually kind of want
to make it bigger
width 100 percent
I then want to get
the data list that exists directly after
that so not any other sibling the one
directly after it because I might have
multiple range sliders
I'm going to get the data list directly
after it and
I set that to be display grid
and I'm going to Define some columns in
my grid
I'm gonna say 50 pixels
repeat
for 1fr
op
2m
50 pixels
so what I'm doing here is I'm going to
define a grid layout and I want it to
have a 50 pixel column on either side
and then I want it to repeat four times
in the middle a column that will grow
and Shrink as I need it to and then a
column that is like twice the base font
size at that point
and if I refresh at the very least I
should see
a whole bunch of labels appearing at the
bottom apologies I know they're a little
bit small but the content of them
not important right now
so I have a whole bunch of labels that
appear under my slider but they're not
aligned
very nicely so now I'm going to go
through and I'm going to get
any my options inside my data list
and
grid column and span three I want it to
spend across three of The Columns that
I've defined grid column starts
one okay now what I am going to want to
do and I highly recommend if anyone's
not familiar with CSS grid and they're a
little bit confused have a look have a
look on NDC conferences YouTube and I've
given a talk on CSS grid a couple of
times once or twice or eight times at an
NDC before so check that one out that's
my little Shameless plug
I'd say for the day but I can't
guarantee it might not happen again
so we're going to go through and this is
where I'm going to start to use a little
bit of magic I want to know how many
labels I need to be laying out
but I can't count how many things
however I has selector back up here I
can start to do some work with that so
I'm already checking for a form and it
has a range input on the inside I'm then
going to check
that must then have an element directly
afterwards it's a data list
the data list should contain an option
and the option should be
the first child that exists
what I can then do is I can define a CSS
variable
option of one because I know it has one
option because that's the first option
that exists inside of it therefore I
know I have at least one option I can
then go through and I can check has
and put
type
range
copilot wasn't working for me earlier
and I had to write all this in manually
but now it's decided to play nice again
so I can type in has input type range
data list option nth child two if
there's an option that's the second
child I know there is at least two and I
Define options to be two
now because of how CSS works with the
Cascade I know that whichever one it
writes down will overwrite the previous
one and I can go through and I can't
count but I can in a very very long
drawn out way
Define and work out how many options I
have available
yeah I'm not writing them all in
now this is where one of the things
where pre-processor or post-processor
being able to programmatically generate
these selectors kind of useful but I can
go through and I can then know on my
form input how many options on the Range
selector it has
so now I can go through in here I have
defined that I want four sets of columns
but I actually want the number of sets
of columns of labels that I have so I'm
going to go through and I'm going to use
my CS CSS variable
and I'm going to Define that many
columns and it's going to create wrong
link
is going to create a whole bunch more
columns and they're going to sit a
little bit weird
so I can go through and do that
right next I want to lay these out a
little bit nicer
so here I've set them to start at grid
column one which is all the way at the
beginning but I don't want to do that I
want to go through and I'm going to
create another CSS variable for column
which I'm going to give a value to in a
second I wanted to start at that one
and because these won't all fit in one
line I actually want each alternate one
to go down a row so I'm going to get any
option
there's an inch child of 2N so every
second one grid row start two so that
should go the next row down and things
will sort of stagger
a little bit so I can go through and do
that
now
what I then need to go through and do
is have my columns
although I think I have them
yep I have them elsewhere so I have
another code where I wrote The Columns
because we don't it going through and
writing this thing again and defining
the columns which we don't need to do
so I can then go through and I can align
all of these nice and neatly along
I think I've got an extra column that I
need I can go through and Define these
nice and nicely all the way along my
range
and I can now see labels
which better align with how I should be
ranking my range slider
so I can go through and do that one last
thing to get this nice and neatly is
quick
little fix I want to go through I've set
this to be width hundred percent but I
don't quite want that I want calc 100
minus 100
divided by the number of options I have
which should give me a nice little gap
on either side so my labels line up a
little bit better
very nice little labels and I can then
tell a little bit more about how I'm
ranking my JavaScript skills
so that's pretty cool
Now browser support on Range slider is
pretty good it's been around for a while
not great oh wait no this isn't
sorry this is on the had selector so
this is the has had my speaker notes
which thing I was testing browser
support for and it's not appearing in my
speaker notes so apologies on that one
this is the has selector no this is the
range slider this is the has select art
so the has selector unfortunately has a
little bit less support available
but it's meant to be coming to Firefox
nope
that one's meant to be coming to Firefox
at some point soon
I'm gonna share my slides at the end and
make sure I tell everybody which element
I'm quoting browser support on uh so
that you can go through and have a look
at that has selecta unfortunately does
not exist in Firefox which makes me
really really sad but I'm really hoping
that is going to change at some point
soon
next
testimonial sliders carousels whatever
you want to call it
we have them on our website that's where
we tell people that we're not weirdos
and we can be trusted in our clients or
new prospective clients should trust us
enough to give us lots of money to do
our jobs
now to build testimonial sliders we can
take advantage of the radio input so we
often use these on forms but instead we
can take advantage of them to show and
hide testimonials depending on what
people have selected
oh
Okay so
testimonials
I can have a look here here I have some
lovely testimonials that some of the
amazing speakers have given me today
about why we don't like JavaScript so
we're going to go through and add them
to a slider
so I want to get testimonials
and display
grid
grid template Rose I wanted to find the
rows
to be one Auto sizing row and then one
row that's as big as it needs to be and
then grid template columns
I'm going to take advantage of my has
selector Hack That I Used before to
repeat
number of testimonials
and I want it to Auto size that column
and then I want one FR to exist on the
end justify content should be Center
because I want everything to Center
nicely
I'm then going to go through and copy
this because we just talked about how
the has selector Works to be able to
count the number of elements that exist
I'm going to go through and count it
does this testimonials element has a
block quote that's the first of its type
I'm specifically using nth of type this
time because there's a whole bunch of
other things in there so I do actually
want to count just the first block quote
second block quote and so on and so
forth
next
I want to go through
and
I'm going to get some inputs
so I want to look for an input
with a type of radio
and I'm going to set that to be display
none I don't want that to appear
I then want to check if a testimonial is
sorry if a radio input is checked
if a radio input is checked I want to
get the label that exists directly after
it and then I want to get the block
quote that exists
directly after it
and I'm going to change the opacity to
be one
and I'm going to change the pointer
events to
be Auto because we're going to go
through and overwrite this in a second
next I'm going to go through and grab
my block quotes
and I'm going to set pointer events to
be none what this means is I can't click
on it and I'm going to set opacity
to be zero
and I'm going to set that to sit
in my grid column 1 to -1 so that will
go from the start to the end so start to
end
and then I'm going to set grid row to be
one to two so I'm being very explicit
about how I'm defining it in this case
because I need to
think this should give us something that
we can have a look at here
Yep this has given us a whole bunch of
things
that don't say anything at all
but I think if I click here
there so I can go through and click on
my different testimonials and they will
show and hide depending on which I'm
clicking on however I don't want people
to click on testimonial I want to give
them something nicer to click on
so I'm going to go through and get my
label
I'm going to use flexbox here to make
things align nicely line item Center
because we all know that's best way to
vertically Center something
I'm going to set the color to be
transparent because I don't want the
text of the label to actually appear I'm
going to set the font size to be one
pixels because I don't want it to appear
what I'm doing now is I'm hiding it
visually but it will still exist for
screen readers so people do actually
kind of know what they're clicking on
and they're going to set a margin of
five pixels to add a bit of a gap
I want the labels to all appear after
the block quotes in the grid so I'm
going to set the order to be two
position relative
uh grid row two because I want them to
start on the second row and I'm going to
change my cursor to a pointer because I
want people to know that they can click
on things so the pointer will give me
it would
I'd say it will give me a nice thing but
we've just established I've hidden it so
they're all one pixels high and I can't
see them
so next
I want to go through and I'm going to
set a before and after
pseudo selector on this give that a
height of 20 pixels
a width of 20 pixels
order radius 50 because I want to make
it round
border two pixels
solid
and I'm going to use my green color that
I have set that to be display block
and then I'm going to go through
and give the content tribute
and
I'm going to give the after attribute a
background
which you're going to copy and paste
I'm going to give that a background and
position absolute it
what I'm then going to do is I can come
back up here so what this should do is
this will then give me a whole bunch of
little dots here so I can go through and
get them there
what I then want to do is go back up
here where this is where I've checked if
a radio
input is checked I show and hide the
testimonial I'm also going to if the
radio input is checked I want that after
the after pseudo selector to appear
as well
and this should give me a nicely styled
functional radio button looking thing
but I could style this however I wanted
to
lastly because on first refresh none of
these are checked which means nothing's
actually appearing
I then want to go through and I want to
check
if
not has input type
radio
checked
I want to get the block quotes that is
the first of type
and set opacity to be one pointer events
to be Auto
and I want to get the first label
and assign that the content so what
that's checking for is I'm using the has
selector to check does my testimonials
element contain a radio input that is
checked if it doesn't this is what my
not selector does if it doesn't contain
one that is checked I'm going to pretend
that the first one's checked I'm going
to simulate that the first one is
checked using CSS which means the first
one will always appear
and I can continue to click through the
rest of them now I do have one little
problem with this little input is
sitting all the way over here by itself
so I'm gonna use a little bit of a hack
I mean not that the rest of this hasn't
been a hack uh I'm gonna get give it the
testimonials element a before pseudo
element I'm going to give that a content
and then I'm going to set grid
row to be two so that's going to set all
the way down there
and grid column start to be one which is
also going to sit all the way down there
and what this does is this will give me
a pretend element to sit in that corner
which will push my other elements all
the way over and my little toggle
selectors have
sitting sitting very nicely in the
center
which is pretty cool so we use the has
selector to go through and count things
uh we talked about the house selector
browser supports relatively new it is
really powerful though and so it's going
to be really exciting anybody here
happen to be a developer for browsers
with anybody here happen to be a
developer for Firefox it'd be really
great to see this come out more because
I'm excited to be able to use this a bit
more
uh the not selector has been around for
a while so that one's got pretty good
support
and
I'm trying to think
of what I'm checking for here I will
find out and get back to you all on this
one something has pretty good support I
want to say it was radio but radio feels
like it's older than this
full disclosure on this
we're using form inputs outside of forms
which isn't great it's not spectacular
for accessibility and it's confusing for
people who are using screen readers so
if you are doing this I would highly
recommend you use Aria labels and
attributes to give more information
about what it is and what each of the
elements are doing also yeah has is not
supported in Firefox so that's not
spectacular
next
toggle switches we love using switches
we love designing switches we love
building switches we love using switches
because it is always so clear whether or
not the switch we have we consented to
give the company all of our information
or have I said no it's not always super
clear but we love using them anyway
this is another way we can take
advantage of radio inputs to simulate a
switch so here I have a number of radio
inputs the radio inputs all have labels
and I also then have a span at the
bottom which I'm going to style to
become my switch
so let's have a look at this
let me have a look at my toggle
so
I should probably look at my toggle page
here
I have radio inputs and I have labels as
we can very clearly see there so I'm
going to look for my toggle and a set
display Flex justify content Center
line item Center because that's the best
way to vertically Center something and I
want to get any label that exists inside
you know I'm going to copy and paste a
bit of this because we don't need to go
through and type I'm going to get any
label that exists inside of my toggle
elements uh I am going to hide the
actual content of the nope I'm not I'm
going to set that
to sit either end and set the font size
and give it a little bit of padding
so this should then
sit next to one another
I then want to go through and get my
inputs
input
type
radio
and I want to get the label that exists
directly after the radio and I'm going
to give it a pseudo element again
I guess that position absolute
I'm going to make the position absolute
the pseudo element exists all the way
around
exactly on the size and then
I'm going to give give it a z index
value so it appears over it so this is
going to create a pseudo element which
just exists over the label
then
wait I already
checked for that okay and then want to
get any input with a type of radio that
has a value
of on
I can check what the form the field
value is I then want to get the label
that exists after that one and I want to
set the order to be two because I want
that to appear at the end of my element
in order to be two
not one
uh then
I want to give that pseudo element
I'm actually going to get that one to
sit all the way on the right hand side
but the left I'm going to use a little
bit of calc magic and I'm actually going
to make that overlap over my switch
when the switch exists
which we'll look at in a second
next I want to go through and check
when the value
should probably actually go through and
actually style my switch first
so I'm going to go through
for my switch which is the span that
exists I guess that display block I want
to size that to be a nice little size
I'm going to give it a border I have a
nice little circle because that's how
switches work and I'm going to put that
in the center there
so here I have a little switch which
currently does nothing so I'm going to
go through and style this to do
something a little bit more
so next I'm going to check
my input with a value of on
when it's checked
when it's checked I would like to get
the switch that appears after it not
directly after it some other time after
it so I would like to switch to appear
some point after it and as I said the
background color
to be
parent color so this will match the rest
of the color that my font is
and I'm going to work with the pseudo
element I've given the switch
two
move to the other side
and
I'm going to give it a bit of a
transition
right 0.5
is in
out
next I want to get
inputs for the value of off
and get the label directly after it
s pseudo elements
I'm just gonna
copy and paste this one so I can talk
about it
I'm going to get
the input with a value of off we're
going to get the label and we're going
to make its pseudo element also overlap
the switch
we're then going to also check if the
radio input
is not checked
we're going to make sure the pseudo
element actually appears what this will
do is this means our pseudo element
appears over the switch
I think I've done something and it's not
working now what it should do is this
will appear over the switch
and we'll make it clickable
this one is not working however this one
at the bottom of the page
is working so here I have a toggle for a
theme selector because we all know that
we love to have dark mode in light mode
and I sort of have a toggle switch so
that I can change it
so how can we do this now CSS has a
media query where we can actually check
the user's device who here has the
device set to dark mode
exactly
we're developers dark mode is the only
correct answer to do things things we
can check whether or not a user has set
their device to dark mode or light mode
and we can change the colors we're using
accordingly however
sometimes people don't always want to
have everything dark mode sometimes I've
there's there are some things where I
prefer some websites in like mode to
Dart mode and I would like the ability
to control that
so we're going to use
our toggle and here I have a bunch of
colors that I can use
and I have some dark colors and some
light colors
I'm just going to copy and paste this in
here
nope not that one
I'm going to copy and paste this
in here and this will go through and
check does my body contain a theme
toggle which has an input of type radio
which has a value of light that is
checked if my theme toggle is on light I
give it my light colors if my theme
toggle is on dark I give it my dark
colors
and
I can now go through
and change dark mode and light mode
no JavaScript
no JavaScript whatsoever
that's pretty cool so we talked about
the has selector not spectacular but
hopefully soon
uh prefers color mode so actually
checking for Native does the device have
dark mode or light mode selectors that's
pretty good so it's worth going through
and using that one
uh similar to testimonials full
disclosure using form inputs outside of
forms where users aren't expecting them
not spectacular so adding Aria labels to
provide additional context
this is also an input and as soon as
someone refreshes the page it will
default the the toggle back to the
original state and it won't save it
however JavaScript could allow you to
add a more complex function or to save
the value in local storage or a cookie
or something and on reload or revisiting
the website or another page you would be
able to go through and save that there
I think we've got just enough time to go
through and have a look at our image
carousels
and I might copy and paste the code over
the image carousels a lot of the HTML is
similar to how we had the block quotes
and we're going to go through and
conditionally hide and show images
based on
what our radio inputs are
I was going to copy and paste this over
so we're using
display grid to align everything nicely
I'm going to have an image in the middle
and I want to have controllers on the
side so the sides are where my radio
inputs are going to go
when the image to stay in the middle I'm
going to set that one to be really big
and I've added a transition
I've added a transition to give a nice
animation
apologies for going through this really
quickly as well uh so if anyone has any
questions on this afterwards feel free
to come and I'll explain the code better
so we're going to add a bit of a
transition on the image because we like
an animated carousel
I'm going through and I'm hiding the
actual content of the labels again but
I'm using a pseudo element to give me a
button to click and then showing and
hiding the pseudo element and the images
based on whether or not the radio input
is checked
and
I am using Arrow emojis for my
buttons and if I go through and have a
look at my carousel I have an animated
functioning image carousel
using no JavaScript whatsoever just HTML
and CSS
so that is pretty cool
browser support for this is a fair bit
better so we're able to go through and
check whether or not things have been
checked but we are using the has
selector in this case which again
Firefox not spectacular
full disclosure
carousels still suck in my opinion
uh I will actively try and discourage
every client that asks for a carousel
from having a Carousel and if they
insist that they do in fact want a
carousel I have what's called a carousel
surcharge where I'll do it but I don't
want to and you're going to pay for the
fact that I think it's a bad idea
carousels not great for accessibility
not great for performance whole
different discussion uh because we're
using form inputs again also not great
for accessibility we're kind of changing
the way people are expecting things
you should also turn off the animation
depending on user settings in case
people have an impairment where they
don't like to have animation on their
screen that they don't expect
you can do this basically I say don't do
any of this but if you build a carousel
this is how you can do it so I've gone
through and copied and pasted a bit of
code and wrote a bunch of code as well
and you know this is a talk so clearly
I'm not going to lie to you I wouldn't
you know fake all of this and make it
seem like this was without JavaScript
and have secretly running JavaScript in
the background so because I know
that you don't trust me
and because I know there's at least one
person who doesn't believe that you can
do this without JavaScript
there is a website which I will post out
on Twitter and blue sky and maybe Master
have I have I missed another Twitter
Blue Sky Mastodon
there's no other ones yet we had another
one yet threads ah I don't want to have
to open threads again
I'll post it on a bunch of social so you
can come and get the link from me
afterwards this website will work
without JavaScript and you can have a
look if you don't trust me I will also
tweet out the code so you can have a
look at it afterwards
JavaScript
is useful it is a very useful tool but
it's not always the answer
going forward I would like you to have a
think about when you're building
something can you do this with HTML are
you trying to put in who has implemented
the date picker
who here implemented a date picker using
a JavaScript package
most of the time we can probably use the
HTML input there are limitations on the
styles that we can apply for it but when
it's a MVP product or it's a mock-up or
an internal product it doesn't actually
matter it's functional it works there's
no JavaScript so next time you go to
implement JavaScript have a think can
you do it with HTML
can you do it with CSS are you using
JavaScript for animations where you
could just use CSS instead
but JavaScript isn't bad so I also want
you to think can JavaScript make it
better is the JavaScript that I'm
writing improving things rather than
making it worse JavaScript is useful for
a lot of things and adds Advanced
functionality but CSS and HTML is great
for the basis JavaScript for making it
better
I also want you to go through and have a
look at some of your code bases and have
a think about whether JavaScript can be
removed is there JavaScript you don't
need anymore can you take it out can you
replace it with something else the other
thing I want you to check is
do you really really need the tracking
script is anybody actually looking at
the analytics results like if you take
it out will anyone actually notice so
have a look at any of the third party
scripts you have running on your on your
website have a think about whether or
not you need it whether or not it's
being used or whether it could be taken
out
now uh I do I I have stickers and I left
them in the hotel so uh
if people want stickers please come and
find me tomorrow and I will remember to
bring the stickers tomorrow are there
any questions
no questions
in that case thank you everybody for
your time this afternoon I hope you
enjoyed it and I hope maybe we can write
a little bit less JavaScript a little
bit more HTML and CSS in future I will
be around for the rest of the conference
so if you have any questions or would
like to have a look at the code or just
want to you know have a wind about
JavaScript come up and find me at some
point afterwards thank you very much and
I hope you enjoy the rest of the
conference
[Applause]